I think we're
back it's going to take uh it a second
to refresh on all the platforms before I
continue with this I'm going to take um
I'm going to try tonight after the
stream maybe I'll I'll stop like 20 30
minutes early uh and then I will uh I'll
like update OBS and try some stuff and
hopefully that'll be
better um I
this is not happening consistently but
it's been happening enough that this is
like really obnoxious because it cuts my
vods into chunks as well so like I don't
get like the full day VOD just Auto
posted on all the
platforms really obnoxious and then it
like spams my uh my X feed as well with
like post of the
reconnects
so whatever I'm going to continue with
this
with this like walkthrough of stuff
because this is partially for my own
thoughts and hopefully people catch the
majority of it and ask if uh if they
miss part of it but basically if you're
in this chunk here if you split the map
into chunks and you're in this chunk
then all you need to do in order to find
uh every possible agent that you need to
be able to see is you look through the
entities and the surrounding
chunks as well as in your own chunk and
this is because like if you're at the
corner over here right you still need to
be able to see uh you need to be able to
see potentially this
far and then you do distance checks and
filter based on
that so this is how the algorithm is
supposed to
work uh and if it by the way if the
connection drops again I'm just going to
take however long it does to just update
OBS immediately if not I'll just stay on
and until we're done
um so
there are a few issues with this though
especially
because I hate to say it but this is
kind of where like we start to need
C++ uh data structures which I didn't
want to include in syon I do have access
to them I didn't want to include
them
but the reason for
this uh is that let's say that I look
into this chunk here right well this
Chunk we kind of need a list of like
agent right agent
One agent
two and this
list we need to get into this for this
list we we need o of
one
access not look
up we need o of one add and delete is
what we need for this
right yeah so we need o of
one actually we
need I don't know why I wrote it like
that we need o of one look up
[Music]
add and
delete is what we
need uh we can do this
so if this structure
is so we use a linked
list and this is actually a 2X it's a
double link
list then this gives
us add and
up so then in order to get look
up we need to
store we would need to store the pointer
to the entry in the
list we need like agent
we would need like node uh we need to
know the node index or
on so we need to know the chunk index
and we also need a
pointer to the
node and the reason for that
is like think about it when you move the
agent from one from one tile to the next
we basically what we need to do is we
need to look up whether we're moving at
chunks so we look up our current chunk
index we look up the index of the chunk
that we're moving to that's just
math and then if we do move to a
different chunk then what we need to be
able to do is O of one look it up in
that list which if we just have a
pointer to the node in the list that
gives us it and if it's a doubly linked
list then we can snip it out of the list
in O of
like if you're doing this with the link
list then you also have dynamic memory
allocations
want like this is totally doable it's
just is it worth it
us this still doesn't trivialize stuff
right even with this fancy data
structure
freaking this web UI is
bad this still doesn't even if we have
this it doesn't trivialize it because
you'd still want to like filter what
agents are near you when what agents are
far away
right which is still going to be slow
you're also doing this chunk lookup
stuff now which
means instead of just going through a
simple array you're going through linked
lists which we're going to assume that
has a decent constant Factor on it as
well
right you're doing iteration through
nine linked
lists I think that in principle this
makes sense and this could work and this
would make this essentially would solve
the problem of having an engine that is
capable of doing
um really good entity based
though I wonder if there there's like
some existing C++ library or something
that does
this there's probably like a C++ like
chunk system I don't know if there's a
one that's as high perf as I would want
though you could totally just like get
one of these things though and then plug
it into any game you
want cuz this is fully
generic this is like completely
generic is there like a C++ chunk
map I don't know what it would be uh
that you'd look
for but that's totally something that I
could
build um that would make this type of
stuff work
it' be a little tricky as well because
you need to do like Vision stuff maybe
well maybe
not I think this is a fun exercise and I
think that this actually gives us a
valid solution to like doing Ultra fast
entity based
processing but this would need a much
more compelling use case I think than
this
yeah it is somewhat annoying that the
vision range is so limited at the moment
though
right only five tiles of vision is
really not a lot to work
with like five in in any
direction I think that's what we have it
set to
which is I think what we did with snake
that we figured out we could handle we
could comfortably handle
that I mean that basically just gives
you local obstacle detection
right I think it'll still be enough to
give you interesting training results
after if we were like 10x off of the
performance
goal I would probably try to do
this because like this is the type of
thing that gets you your your
performance it's very hard to implement
something like this but when you do it
right this is what gives you your perf
goal but I think for what I have now I
probably can get
there more
easily with the current structure and a
few
changes though it does mean I'm probably
going to have to copy paste some code
because we're going to have to get rid
of this double iteration thing that's
going
on some limitations for
sure but I think this will be good
enough if I tried to do this thing this
would
be this would be potentially multiple
additional days of
work for this and
uh I'm going to keep this in mind
though because this is a good Standalone
project right there this is like this is
the type of thing that you would
actually do in Native uh Native C or C++
by the way like this thing here this is
what you would have you would implement
this in C or C++ and then you would plug
it into every single like game sim that
you write thereafter and you'd have like
really good entity based
processing uh lots of games have
something like
this lots of games have something like
this with the chunk
system but I would wager that the vast
vast majority of them are not as
optimized as I would need it to be for
this like you need a really optimal
chunk
implementation let's take a look at what
we have going on
currently oh and I mentioned this before
folks but if the stream goes down again
I'm just going to take however long it
takes to update OBS and see if that
fixes it because the internet I think is
blipping but the internet's blipping for
like a second and then OBS is blipping
for two minutes
so I don't know what's
PX uh right we were looking at the HTML
version Let's do let's go back to
the plan right now so I can do this in a
reasonable time
frame I actually should probably go make
my shake
first so I'm going to go outline I'm
going to outline the plan take the three
minutes or whatever to make myself a
shake and then we're going to implement
it we're going to do a little bit of
caching I'll go through the plan we're
going to do that it should take about an
hour and then we'll have you know an
hour hour and a half maybe two hours
left for uh reinforcement learning
policies tonight which is about on track
with what I wanted that where I wanted
the project to be anyways so this is the
performance critical piece of code uh
one very very minor optimization is I'm
going to get rid of this
addition right here by uh doing this as
like y minus radius y Plus radius so on
and so forth so that we don't have the
addition in the Inner
Loop then I'm going to
do uh is there anything else that can be
pre-computed
here no so I'm going to do that let me
see if there's any other places for
obvious
optimization into player y player
X this is fully discreet so I'm going to
allow you to pass
in no this is
fine yeah so
I'm going to move this target type
down because you don't need it
immediately I'm going to maybe reorder
these a little
bit in terms of how common they
are we're going to see what we get out
of
that and then what I'm going to do and
this is the part that pains me a little
bit but I don't think that we can have
this structured the way it is I think
I'm going to make a code commit first
before I mess with it because uh this
could potentially just screw up a bunch
of the nice code that we have here
but this like scanning idea was
cute but the way that we're scanning
doesn't allow us to Cache anyways
without making a massive data
structure well hold on maybe it does
maybe it
does what if I change
this what if I made those optimizations
I just said
and I just made it so that every player
has its own scan
map or every entity has its own scan
map that's a decent amount of
data not a huge amount though not too
bad if we give every player its own scan
map then what that means is
that scan map is automatically cached
until you call this function
again are you going to do scan map and
then intersect with entity
positions uh the scan function does give
you entity POS like this does give you
that
already because it gives you all the
agents that are within a chubby Chev
square around you so will what we were
doing before is I was looking at this uh
I found there is a way to do a really
hyper efficient chunk system uh that
would then scale to like it would let
you scale to much larger Vision ranges
and um it would really it would let you
scale to much larger Vision ranges is
the main thing and it would be really
snazzy but I think it would be like
multiple days of work and it would be
the type of thing that I would probably
have to build in like C or C++ native
because it's got memory allocations
maybe I could cize it but it would have
to be like a standalone module that's
perf tested alone and then integrated
into this as like a like an engine
add-on it's not
simple it's it's just a chunking system
but it has to be an ultra high
performance chunking system like you
need a data structure that has all of
One everything and the constant Factor
on that matters a lot so it's a little
bit
rough but what I I was kind of looking
at is I think that the easier way to hit
a million steps per second right now uh
we can hit a million steps per second
per core right now if I think all I have
to
do is there are a couple obvious
optimizations on this that'll get me
like 5 10% more out of this function and
then I think all I have to do is um if I
make it so that every player has their
own cash of
scanning
then I make them I I make call this scan
AOE function like the creeps can call
this once every uh once per second
instead of five times per
second and that is a 80% reduction in
the bottleneck step it should be at
least like um a 2X performance gain
overall and then that gives me
immediately that gives me my 1 million
SPS single
thread without even doing anything else
and that's actually what DOTA does I'm
pretty sure the DOTA creeps don't scan
every frame they Scan they scan like
once per second
for targeting
purposes so I'm pretty sure that will
just do it for
us why does the step function say 4
seconds total time
oh that's fine
yeah
so we're at 189,000 steps per second
right
now the step function looks super slow
but I think that this is just function
call
Overhead because it's just calling [ __ ]
tons of internal
functions um this because this has been
lower ratio
before the creep Ai and neutral AI are
dominant ated by which are the the main
sources these are dominated by the scan
AOE
function so I think if I just make the
scan AOE function 5x Faster by caching
80% of
it I think we just get our we get this
to like say 400 or
500k uh and this is on my local desktop
which is at least or at most twice as uh
half the speed of the other
one uh of the like the main
machine so that's what we're going to do
we're going to make those
optimizations and uh we're going
to get our million steps per second and
then we're going to move on to the uh
the initial RL stuff uh there's one
additional optimization that we're going
to have to make which is actually going
to funny enough make this be much faster
uh and maybe this will even be more
impactful than all the stuff I'm doing
now but we're going to do
multi-environment
vectorization maybe not ini we'll decide
but we're going to make it so that like
you can batch run lots of different
environments while without going back to
python we're going to batch in
scyon um
yeah between those two we definitely get
over a million
SPS okay uh I'm going to go make my
shake that'll take me I don't know three
or five minutes we're going to come back
we're going to get our million steps per
second we're going to pass go we're
going to collect $200
uh and then we are going to hopefully
have a bit of time to start on the RL
today I'll be right
let's go claim our million steps per
second
this it's not going to be that
hard really not going to be that
hard let me fix the AC real quick as
well one
so we need to find the data structure
that we're using which is scanned
targets right here so we have this is a
200 length struct struct
do
Max
and can't assign this here can
you yeah we can't do that we have to do
Max scan targets is going to
be up here I
think let's just do let's just do it as
a CA
uh it's Vision times V we can save a
little bit of memory here so it's it's
11 * 11
and then what we're going to do is we're
just going to do
um and where is
it I don't initialize it do I I
should
scanned
Targets this gets initialized somewhere
doesn't it self. scan targets
huh oh no of course it doesn't get
initialized because it's not
uh it's not a 2d okay that's
fine
so we need Max
entities and Max G
targets uh we're going to make this 256
for
now and then we're just going to add a
little Asser in to just catch ourselves
for when we inevitably forget this and
out of bounds this because this is one
of those janky uh non checked
Cays so what we're going to do is we're
going to
assert
uh num agents
plus this has got to be less than equal
Max entities
uh and then it's going to be self.
obiz times self. obiz is got to be less
than
Max
scanned
okay so
now with the scan targets we just have
to update this
function to scan by uh PID and entities
do have a PID associated with them so as
long as I've remember remembered to set
it
correctly which hopefully I have we will
see let me just check yeah Towers got
PID and spawn neutral got a PID spawn
Reep has a pit and then obviously I know
the players have a pit perfect
so this actually sets this up very nice
so uh
scan scan
do we just need int
PID
play. PID and this is actually PID
idx is equal to Target
this is PID
idx and that's
it now wherever we use a when we
wherever we use the scan targets we of
course we have to update this as
well PID equal player.
PID Target equal scan Target PID
idx scan targets we just have to update
this everywhere we use it PID
l. PID
PID this is also uh inefficient we
should cache
this target is scan Target and then if
Target
targets that's
it I think these are the oh right here
we missed
anything this is a big
change we broke lots of things of
course cannot convert python
push player
Target oh that's
weird uh we
do well this is I guess we just copied
this or something because this doesn't
make any
sense
um yeah so we we do
entity start
Target we don't need
this xit this is
good that do
it invalid index type in in oh right
this is not
the can I make this a memory View
obnoxious I can make a 2d entity right
though
right let me
see not
allowed wait not allowed in a constant
expression array Dimension not
integer incomplete well let's make sure
I'm allowed to do this first
Targets this looks correct to
me uh maybe there you're not allowed to
do this cuz it's not like a constant or
ofine
nope well that's
fine we'll just hard code Max
targets I know can you initialize stuff
here like
assign
oh hold
on I'm just getting a ray syntax
confused I believe
it's is the syntax right
back maybe I'm allowed to use
this I should be able to
right unless it's like hey this isn't a
constant what if I do constant
I don't know if it ignores it or not
we'll
fine const correct code is
stupid
anyways o not allowed in a constant
I guess we are not allowed to do it
after all
huh that
sucks so we were write the first time I
think it's because you don't have
constants and like pound
defines that you're not allowed to do
this because it it doesn't know that
this is going to not it doesn't know
that this is a constant at compile time
right so it's like hey this [ __ ] might
change um so I think we're like you
can't even
this I think you just put a comment here
Max this is like
right and then you just hope that this
you can't even do these asserts you just
hope you don't screw it
up actually there is one thing we can
ourselves so this is real dumb but it
gives us the same don't shoot ourselves
in the foot
errors I do wonder if we
should
Alias I actually don't know how that
works if you can pass or
raise um we're going to just swap the
syntax like this for now and if it's
really slow we'll change it it should
not be really slow though
let's see if this actually runs now or a
perf
test it should be same speed but you
never
speed pretty much spot on same speed so
now the thing is the reason we just did
that is so we can cache
right let me figure out uh well there's
one other optimization we can do first
that's a little easier so let's do
that here it
is so what we're going to do this is no
longer going to be Y and X
player
Y is player
X
right and what we're going to do is now
we're going to do int
y x it's now y this is X this is layer
Yus radius player y +
radius player xus
radius like this now this PID map
doesn't have to do any math on the
index which is very
nice we also move this target
type down to
here because we don't need
it um
exclude friendly before exclude
hostile the most commonly excluded type
I believe
is it's the creep
targeting creeps don't Target
neutrals and neutrals don't Target each
other though I think that this is fine
either
way uh and then we do scan targets
perfect return idx greater than zero so
this should be the exact same thing it
may or may not make a performance
difference this is a very small
optimization but this is the most
performance critical piece of code in
the entire project so it is possible
it is faster than before but it's
potentially within the
noise I mean it's definitely faster we
don't know how by how much if it's
substantial or not but who cares we have
it as fast as it can reach reasonably be
now uh and the only thing we have left
to do is implement the caching so let's
do
AOE and and how do we do this found
Target
through scan targets pit is equal to
null so this actually doesn't even have
to return
this so there are like a few places
where we call the scan
AOE let's start with the
uh the creep
AOE and then we do if self.
scanned is not equal to
null zero
in
PID
now there's some follow-up logic
PID now there's some follow-up logic we're going to probably have to do once
we're going to probably have to do once
we implement this because the caching is
going to make a few things a little bit
weird but um we have self. tick anywhere
yeah we do have self.
tick if self.
tick percent
5 is equal to zero we
scan and that's literally
it and now let's do the neutral one
player AOE attack can still have a
updated scam AOE push can have an up
these are all
simple I think the towers can even have
uh
ticks for the
tower in 6 seconds it's a little
uh and then this is the last place right
here
weot to Define
PID
we actually don't need found Target
creep AI we probably don't need it in
creep AI either
right uh is there a found
Target oh guess
not so if this works this is the last
piece of the puzzle I think to get us
the the perf we need
m.p not as big as a uh as an increase as
I would have
thought but now actually like almost
this so much of this time is in the step
function that you almost don't
know I think we should here we should
compile we should compile this without
um without C profile on or without uh
what is
it we should compile this without
profile director on directive
on because I still don't know how much
overhead the function calls are
so scon profile false
right there's still some stuff that we
probably need to be uh caching in the
the attack
functions let's see how close we are
though
oh we're there we
win
cool
um that's well let's see if this
actually hold on before I say we're
there
oh look it's the exact same game we
didn't break anything that's
amazing at least nothing critical it
looks the exact
same okay so there you have it guys um
this is
680,000 steps per
second uh we started today at
70,000 so we got a 10x
Improvement and uh as I've said several
times this is my local desktop here
which is an old machine the puffer boxes
which are the target Hardware uh which
is just a higher-end desktop those cores
are at least twice as fast so this is
well over a million steps per second and
mind you this is with um where is
it well you can't even see the total
amount of overhead because it's not
showing you but um this is uh a low-end
estimate as well because we're also
going to vectorize this so we can do
multiple copies of the environment at
the on the same scon
process so that's going to bump this up
a whole bunch as
well so there you
go we hit
it 10x perf Improvement in a
day I think that's pretty good that's
pretty good
progress um
could it be faster yeah it could be
faster it could definitely be faster but
uh this is going to allow us to do
pretty much everything we
need uh yeah they're going to be allow
us to do pretty much everything we need
so it's a little bit awkward for uh the
reinforcement learning side at the
moment because I do kind of need to
write that binding don't
I I do kind of need to write the binding
for
that you not really going to be able to
do RL until I have the multi uh the
multiprocess not the multiprocess
multiple environments uh
per per scon process because right now
there's a there's a 250 some odd
megabyte map that needs to be shared and
if you don't share it properly if you
just like make a bunch of different
processes and all load it up uh then
it's going to be way too
slow
256 258 I don't know what it was
megabyte pathing data
I'm going to commit this for now though
and uh we're going to run it on maybe
we'll run it on one of the bigger boxes
just for
fun want this data
file this mobile
file want this pre-computation
file and we want the setup file anything
it oh do we want this MOBA per
file maybe just for
on this just weird we had this before
this is just weird pip
Shenanigans I think you just have to run
these a couple times until
it I don't know it's
weird how about now
now you can see it's building something
even though I just built it because it's
taking that long
bizarre it was literally what I did last
time and it
worked is
dumb okay what the hell is there a file
missing
here there is an underscore underscore
knit that I forgot to commit
I think that's what it was it was just
the inet
file I don't know if it was the PIP
install or the build that made it work
though obviously these things that will
be worked out before
release but this is the type of boring
thing where if I were to get it
understand exactly what's happening and
now I'd be scratching my head for three
hours there we
go it was just the init file
correct multiply and it should be
multiplied by 10 right number of ticks
times 10 because there are 10
right this can obviously shift by a
reasonable Factor depending on what's
going on in the game but I think is an
initial perf test
we are
set
30 4 million function
calls
appreciated I this is so stupid how the
internet works this stupid post of mine
has a thousand likes on it
views so ridiculous how that works and
it doesn't get you like it doesn't
convert anything it's just like
congratulations on your internet points
you made a funny
joke all
right do I post the GIF again or do I
just post the perf screenshot I probably
post the GIF again right even though
it's repetitive
I think you have to reexport a gift
though so that it gives you a
different you doesn't record you as like
posting the same Media or whatever let's
do that real
quick and then uh we actually will get
to do the the multi like the multi
whatever multi environment thing that I
was talking about and then we get to do
a little RL
just a little bit
today I said Thursday at the latest
we'll get to start it you know Wednesday
evening that's on
track gives us all day tomorrow to work
out good policy
stuff obviously we're not going to have
like the game being solved immediately
but oh hello there let me I didn't see
your message because the thing was oh no
that's just will that was from earlier
this thing covers the transparent whoop
transparent
UI I think we screwed up here as well
hold
on I hate the windows thing that just
like yeah let me minimize all your stuff
on where did everything
go uh here here this is
this we need self this is self. outcome
now it should work it needs to just be
able to know when the game's over
steps uh oh is it behaving
differently we getting no radiant just
took tier
three dire took tier three as well dire
just took tier four radian has taking
tier four it's very close
game long game as
well and there you
go that looks like a radiant
Victory radiant victory
Docker dire Victory so this is actually
radiant
Victory right
where is
it my file
cool it's actually radiant victory
there we
nice okay
so that's
fun I promised 1 million steps per
second I delivered 1 million steps per
second um now it's mostly just what can
we train with this and know a few more
Integrations we obviously like there's a
whole bunch of stuff that's not fully
implemented in the game that we're going
to have to do but uh this is kind of
enough to get
started it's pretty
stable I think that there's
um I mean even with this like there's
probably some cool stuff the agents
could learn
right now whether they're smart enough
to learn it who
knows they kind of actually have to at
least go down the
lane but probably if you give them some
like really basic objective function
like if you just give them a reward for
going for getting to the enemy Tower or
the enemy
Fountain they'll probably learn to do
something
yeah they'll learn to do something
cool I have no idea how cool but I'll be
okay so the one other thing that we have
to figure out how to do here which is
trivial we just have to figure out how
to run these things in a loop
basically I did this in
uh I think I did this in snake didn't I
grid see
grid
oops oh did I not do it
here maybe I did it in snake
yeah right
here
so I have this step all
function that takes a list of
M yeah okay I remember so this is
actually pretty
easy so what you do is you make a list
of you just make a list of these
environments on the python
side and
this isn't perfectly
scyon um it's not
perfect but uh it's better than vanilla
for calling steps in a
loop um by a substantial
margin and it'll it'll still uh break up
a little bit of call
Overhead
and I think the main thing was the way I
was splitting up actions right
step where is it get m.
step oh no was the way that I was
populating the action vectors I
believe so if you look at like snake
here if you look at the uh the coal it's
kind of clever how it
works so you get this pointer through
end like this and this is why I always
Point people to this snake example it
has everything so you have a pointer and
you have the end
and you're just giving each environment
a slice into this buffer but this is
this slice is a memory view so you
basically just have everything in one
giant tensor and then you just give
different slices to different sub
environments and that means that when
you populate you know you vectorize
populate all your data and numpy on the
python side it's immediately updated for
all the scyon
MS so that's pretty cool
yeah let's let's do
this I actually kind of want to leave
this up as a reference for myself
somewhere
go oh yeah we also have to handle resets
fast because I just straight up didn't
do that
that's almost more important but we'll
get to
RL what did we do here like num
Ms yeah
we gave a lot of parameters for this
one a DOTA is actually simpler in this
sense because it's like not procedural
it's
fixed num
M's equals I don't know four
M's
okay
num num M's it's num M's like
this and uh how do we do
it we make the buffer flat
yeah we made it flatten gave
slices why did we do that
uh I did it because it makes sense with
the observation spaces to do it that way
so you may as well do everything that
way it does make it
slightly more Awkward to do some
stuff but I think it's
it oh no I remember why I did it that
way the reason I did it in the snake
doesn't apply here
we're
fine we can do this more reasonably so
we get the game map we get the
grid we get um pids like
this I think this grid has to be a copy
doesn't it
yeah grid totally has to be a
copy remind me to do
that pids is going to be
zeros we add
num num M's to
this C
entities
Okay C OBS player self. numm comma
then
observations we can get total agents
here right num
times I think this is actually has to be
like this
10 yeah this is 10
it's always
10 m agents
is
correct correct correct
correct and we don't use this
okay now we get to the interesting part
here c
m
okay
CM like
so and we do four I in range num
Ms we need um
pointer we actually don't need pointer
because we did it way easier this time
didn't we
so it's going to
be I
comma reshape numb agents OB
size wait that's weird isn't
it oh no it's not this
is we we had it right but it's lowered
down this so This goes down here this
goes down here
colon
observations uh what is observations
buff
observations numb agents nope this is
correct over here
so I I'm just doing like various like
little tiny annoying bits of
tensor uh manipulation in my head they
they're kind of hard to explain but
they're very basic I'm just basically
I'm figuring out if data needs to be uh
three dimens dial tensors or two
dimensional tensors and the difference
would be that the threedimensional
tensors have number of environments
comma number of Agents comma whatever
and the two-dimensional ones are just
going to be like numb agents times
number environment so you roll them
all yes we got self. agents we've got
um entities
do
entities which we did uh OBS
players we did num
M's
what no we're fine um we're we're fine
so this is self grid. this needs a
copy self. AI pass this is not a copy it
doesn't get modified it's
mutable well not really immutable but be
nice this gets
I okay
VI
append self. C entities I entity data is
shared OBS players is not
shared uh OBS View
you know it's still it you end up having
to slice anyways because these rewards
and stuff are
flat I think it's probably better to
just do everything flat huh
it's really obnoxious because otherwise
you have to have a whole bunch of
different views
yeah
okay we'll do it that way I'm losing I
I'm losing a bit of steam here but I
want to at least get this to work I want
to have it so that we can run multiple
environments without blowing up
memory um though actually it did I do
recall memory blowing up anyways but
we're going to see about this um if we
don't do this we definitely blow up
memory because we don't share the the
pathing maps and the pathing map is 200
uh 200 some odd Megs and we're going to
need like a 100 of these
environments more 400 of these
environments per
core we're probably going to be running
like 800 some odd
environments so that's a lot of
memory 800 copies of do is pretty
fun did they actually tell you in open5
how many copies of DOTA they
core I don't think they told you how
many
um how many
copies but uh if they were using 128,000
cores I are they running the game single
threaded I would assume the game just
runs single threaded doesn't it
well actually no the game shouldn't run
single threaded right but still they're
running
like they're probably running tens of
thousands of copies of the game at
least I could ask him that oh they also
give you that they have 20,000 numbers
so that's like 80 KB observations which
is Big so give you their observation
size they have a lot of data they're
pushing lots and lots of data they're
crazy project
this actually what am I talking about
this is all fine I literally all I have
to do is compute um some pointers
each um
agents OBS
view that's it I
guess
creeps this numb agents is wrong this is
be 10 I'm neutrals Towers Vision
whatever this is
fine it's
this turn buff
observations what's this the step thing
we'll do the step in Python to start
we'll save a little bit when we oops
when we move to
scyon uh you need
pointer do you need pointer
here well this is the big spot you're
losing a lot as well we're going to do
it this way for now but there's an
optimization here n plus equal 10
okay so you just do like
this pointer colon
end
okay this is
fine I think the render just takes the
first one
right self. client. render grid
oh but because you're giving it a
copy uh this is going to be kind of
awkward
do if
I zero grid equal
so like render and gets true good render
and gets
true
grid
otherwise the grid gets updated in
place and you can't have all the
environments updating the same end but
you'll just give it this
grid
uh this is
may be
fine
yeah
okay and then when you do render let me
see where's
render self. client render grid
pids
zero
[Music]
um uh star
10 this probably going to take a second
to get correct I'm assuming
right but basically as soon as this
works oh yeah we didn't change that demo
en mode
eal
remote as soon as this
uh as soon as this Works we're pretty
much set I we have to still do past
resets but uh other than
that that's pretty much like complete
Loop argument
[Music]
zeros right so we have to add some
parentheses
here num
environments probably num M's right
I think it's probably about the
same but we'll do a perf test before and
after we add the step function in I
guess we have to pass uh M's here don't
we
M's okay and then we'll
pass is it
[Music]
environments we'll see if this gives us
something that makes sense or
not we're expecting it to be the same as
before
roughly maybe a little
faster we haven't really done the op
optimizations that let you take
advantage of this yeah same
speed same
speed there's some optimizations we can
make of course um let's make a very
small one right now
this is
[Music]
environment okay
and then
death and all we do
is oh I haven't implemented this action
thingy
yet how obnoxious is
that it's going to take me like five
minutes it's not that hard I'm just
tired let's uh let's just do
it it not that hard
actions all we have to do so this is a
fun trick you just cheat your actions
into the environment as a mem copied
buffer um so we have
Rewards well self. buff.
actions pointer through
end right so all we just did is we just
cheated the actions in
Here and Now
all we have to do is
yeah it's just self-d actions these are
separate
and then when you do step this is pretty
cool
actions and then because you've cheated
actions in you don't have to pass them
as an argument anymore so there's no
data transfer there it's just in place
and then you just do step all self.
CMS you comment this because this thing
does not need it you don't need this
anymore you edit uh simoa
words because we have to add float uh
actions here
float actions like
this
CNP bad suggestion there CNP ND
array
rewards okay so now we get Rewards
uh nope not rewards that's what we had
before
actions
rewards self. actions equal to
actions very nice
uh this is kind of cool actually
because step there was it B
function yeah this is allowed to stay
aan but this is kind of cool because
what this lets you do this was a CP def
before right which means this calls back
to python when you call call it this is
now a
CDE that takes no
arguments so now you have this def
function that's
python but it's really fast because this
is this Loop
going type this
index
I yeah there we
actions oh this is actually even
funnier but this is self. actions here
there going to be an opportunity to make
this even
view right this is actually a 2d array
the actions are uh two-
dimensional no big
deal
float unsigned int
self
actions
um we have discretise on right now don't
we or don't we do we or don't we I think
it's I think we have it not right
but I think it's like this right actions
continuous
py list get item yeah we need this from
SE snake or was it what we have this
in snake SE
solid well we got that now let's see
does
it probably not a huge performance
difference ooh expected float got
unsigned
integer that's not good
integer this is float
32 I
well hold
on some shenanigans
this is definitely supposed to be a
and why is it only
10 should be num agents
agents uh this ought to
be this actions should be
dots No
Sol but
okay this is
weird this looks
good but for some
reason we don't have the right number of
Agents being
good what is it that makes this pick up
the number of AG
agents would think it would just be
agents
right when you do
agents per M yeah it's numb
agents self.
Ms so this numb agents should be
correct I'm just trying to figure out
why it's not it doesn't it's not
registering that I have 10 environments
correctly I'm passing to the norl
net
okay that's up a little bit right that's
a little bit of performance we're now at
600 uh 700k
right and I'm going to risk running
100 uh if my computer explodes see you
when I get a new one
it's actually nice in memory
performant that was stable I guess it's
the renderer that has a weird leak in
it funny that that decreases depths per
second
though assumedly it's just like
different parts in the game or
whatever we'll leave it at
10 don't worry we'll we'll have
consistent 1 million because we have a
few additional like vector uh
optimizations we can make along the way
so the 1.3 million I posted I it'll be a
nice consistent at least a
million there you go there's your seven
709k with 10 environments so 100
agents and like I don't know 2,000
minions or
whatever and the 700k remember it gets
more than double on the other box so
that's like 1.5 million now probably 1.4
at
least okay so uh there we go there's our
VC
implementation multi-m I guess You' call
it
multiple so this is technically enough
that I could start on the network or I
could make the reset function be more
reasonable I kind of want to start on
the network
design just a little
tricky at least it's going to be tricky
to do
got so Clemens has this real cool
blog we does this entity neural
networks 100,000 steps per second on a
single GPU I'm going to assume that I
have a better GPU so let's say I get
200,000 but that's still too
slow this is a criminally underrated
project by the way I thought this was
way bigger he kind of just quietly
released this with one blog post and
didn't promote it too much um this is
like an awesome awesome project why the
hell don't I have this star give him a
star main one at
least
um oh this is so funny I forgot that he
did snake as
well I should message him on this
it didn't document this it doesn't think
it has a nice renderer on
it oh but his m is in
Python isn't
it yeah he did all this like efficient
stuff but then the uh the M logic is in
Python
happy this was like a cool demo as well
I should chat with him about this stuff
he's around an SF I
know he does like really high per
engineering on this side um what I'm
basically just trying to figure out
is if his neural network architecture is
remotely reasonable for the level of
perf I'm going for
he's got this ragged attention thing
which I don't need it to be ragged I
just need
attention
um I don't know if he did multi-headed
attention or if he just did attention
either oh it is a multi-headed attention
so he said he has a proc experiment
thing as
architecture by attention I think he
means multiple multi-headed attention
because he mentions it before let me
feature 10 so these are really
small so he's using like 10,000
parameters but the thing is if you're
only getting 100,000 steps per second
with 10,000 parameters like our
implementation on the snake environment
is way faster than this because on our
snake end we have 150k and we get a
million steps per second
I should definitely catch up with
Clemens though he does really awesome
work and uh before I like the
engineering I was doing was like
relatively low perf by comparison but
now now with the latest stuff it's
actually like really fast and you know I
can I can play ball with these numbers
uh with the latest Sim stuff which is
really cool
is really
uh this is them like doing some
comparisons
okay I still don't know if this
attention block is
reasonable because if this attention
block is limiting you to 100 KPS with
that little data then I'm pretty sure
that you're just straight up not going
to be able to use it in uh in our
setting it scales
quadratically
and quadratic
among yeah you can't do like well if you
had like 20 agent like 20 entities 20 by
20 is 400 400 times 32 I think that's
already too
big
oh I forgot that he credited me for the
review I did not contribute very much to
this whatsoever this was really his
project he did awesome awesome work with
this but uh this list of like reviewers
is awesome Chris bamford's awesome cost
is
awesome is a really cracked project
I remember telling him I wasn't sure
about the handdrawn uh like the
handdrawn style like this but I was
totally wrong this is
awesome
well this kind of tells
us
the this kind of tells us though right
that we're not going to be able to do
this so
let's look at the DOTA architecture for
other
inspiration if it's not clear the point
of what I'm doing now is I'm looking for
like feasible architectures for this
thing um I can draw it out maybe that'll
help me and that'll be interesting there
are a couple people still watching this
so I'll draw it
so the way that you uh you look at
this you have 2D map
data okay you have 2D map data that you
get this is like if you
are yeah if you're
here you're like this agent
oops what the heck that's
weird why would you ever
so you have this type of a thing here
this is like your
vision and you have your I drew it like
an even size it should be an odd
size but let's say you have your agent
like here
right and then you have
right and like maybe you have a wall
here okay so you get like your terrain
map and maybe you
have orange maybe you have like another
agent over here that you can see
right so this just gets interpreted as
one hot so this gets
so this basically
like say this becomes zero this becomes
one uh or more likely this becomes here
this becomes
one this becomes two and like this
becomes three
okay and then you put this into your
convet which I'm going to attempt to
draw like this
of and then you get this into a flat
vector and then the architecture for
this is that you put this into an lstm
and then you put this into an action
head this is your classic architecture
this is what I use on snake it runs a
million steps per second as long as you
use small
comps but the thing is with
uh with this project the thing that's
difficult is you also get
these these like entity
entity all right
and this is the thing I need an
architecture for and this is hard
because like this is set data and it's
kind of a lot of set data we're going to
assume this is like
20 20 X20
maybe um mix mixed discreet and
continuous though we might be able to S
side step
that
so this is 400
this is almost already too big just
looking at this though we can probably
limit this to be like
um if we limit this to be bytes it's not
that
bad if this is like 20 x 20 bytes that's
not
terrible though if we're making this
float
data Maybe if it's fp16 data it's
okay it's kind of a lot
we're going to have to figure some stuff
out we're also going to have to think
about like what you get from these
entities that you can't get
normally you know it's possible that we
could just encode all this [ __ ] into the
map that might be
better let's look at some architect to
see if we have some reasonable weight so
basically it's just like you have a
bunch of different agents around you
right that have different
properties and that's a lot of data to
encode so the two different options I
have are try to stick this into the map
somehow which I have ways of doing it's
not
impossible um and I even have ways to
compress that data if I need
to the it is kind of continuous data
which is a little
wonk uh but that's one
option it's a little awkward to do it
that way because then you still have to
like you have to Output a Target on the
map which is
hard maybe it's not that
hard it might not be that hard honestly
Decon the the thing is the entity based
architecture is just really
cool and it's a really nice opportunity
to do
it but I don't know how fast it'll be
let me look at opening
quick we might even want to just time
some different architectures you know
okay so this is the hard thing right
here you see how they have unit one
through
N I guess you can't see this on the
screen here so this is here this is unit
one through n they've got like a big
stack of units same thing as we have
they've got a really fancy encoder but
ignore it this is just like an MLP
basically um you have all these
different units and you need to pick one
so again they have fancy architecture
yada yada it doesn't matter the key
thing is that you eventually you get an
embedding for each of these so if
they're like 20 units you're going to
get 20 32 dimensional vectors or
something and then you have these as
unit attention Keys you dot product them
with the output of an lstm and then you
use this for
targeting it's a pretty reasonable way
of doing uh targeting to be
stuff the thing that's really obnoxious
about entity data like
this is like you can kind of do
everything with 2D Maps right like if
you think about it the thing that I just
drew I can kind of do everything with 2D
Maps like if I just output a 2d map of
like hey these are where I want to
attack then I I don't have to even think
about this
information but the thing is the the
reverse is not
true I can't just do everything in terms
of entity data because you still need
the freaking 2D map because you need to
know that you're not pathing into
obstacles you need to know the
terrain so it's essentially like either
do everything in 2D map and try to make
that as good as possible or you have to
split it and now you have two things to
optimize and optimizing The Entity one
is not easy because like there's an
existing architecture that works
perfectly for this it's a Transformer
but it's too
the fact that
like image gen models exist like DC
again generative image
models even the really early
ones that kind of tells me
that it's reasonable to
do map data in map data
out
right so the architecture I'm imag now
is you have an input that's like a big
stack of channels it's like a very many
ched image where like some of the
channels are map data but the other
channels are for entity data and you get
it to be like some reasonable number
maybe you compress it right
whatever uh you do whatever you need to
do
there but the idea is like at the end of
the day you're going to end up with some
number some reasonable number of
channels of data it's all one data type
it's just like a 3D thing 3D block of
numbers you do like a con
layer you do like one or two con layers
and a fully connected you put it through
your
lstm and then the the decoder head is
going to be the
opposite so the decoder head will
do hidden Dimension
there are a lot of basic architectures
you could use for this actually now I'm
thinking about it
you could even do like one by one coms
or
whatever that's essentially an entity
well
yeah I think we need to probably code up
one of these little architectures though
and see how fast it is don't we
I've got an
hour that'd probably be kind of fun to
watch right we code up uh we're not
going to integrate it or anything but
like we can code up a little test
architecture just to see how reasonable
it is and like if this thing runs a
million steps per second then all we
have to do is optimize the rest of the
data Pipeline and it'll train it a
million steps per second or
whatever I mean I guess we have to like
estimate the train versus the forward
pass and stuff
overall how could this screw
up well the one way that I see if this
screws up is
like the action Space is really big
right yeah your action space is like 20s
something
dimensional well that's like a discreet
of
it but like if you do an entity based
one and you say like let's say you limit
it to 20 nearby Target targets you have
a discreet of
20 you don't get any positional
awareness you have to learn
it I think we try
it I mean
is there anything else we could
do the other thing we could do that
would be way
Jank but uh would let us actually get
something working
initially and this is probably where we
should start to be honest though it's a
lot less
fun is let's say we just load up all the
data that we want into this uh this
image format right we prepare all the
data we make a reasonable
Network and then we just totally punt on
targeting right we just like script
which agent you're going to hit and then
we let the agents learn uh they learn
the movement they learn their button
presses
right that'd probably be way easier to
get started
I bet you if I go that
route I can have something
training on somewhat reasonable data at
somewhat reasonable perf by the end of
the day tomorrow if I go that
route whereas if I do this this is like
Uncharted
Territory and the thing is if I do the
safe version of this I have a pretty
darn easy way to like try to
expand cuz like yeah there's no world in
which
it's pretty much in every possible case
doing the first one makes the second one
easier and doing the second one first is
like really really really
this let's just try it this way let's
figure
out how we're going to mess
with all this map
data it's a pretty safe format as well
it keeps the network architectures very
uniform
um
yeah I mean technically all we need is
the map data to start with
right yeah we we just need the map data
to start with technically all
right let's see what what [ __ ] we
have in here that we can
adjust
[Music]
observations what is
this oh this is kind of
fine uh this function is
slow so what we're going to do is
see yeah we're going to want to do this
and see
somewhere buff.
observations yeah so right
here you can see this is self. obiz
self.size plus three
right so
it's actually pretty easy for me to know
how to structure
this see OBS player C OBS
view self. OBS
view let's do this is M OBS view
map obs view
onward and we'll do OBS
view uh OBS view of I
oh is this I correct wait OBS
view re yeah this is fine so OBS view
I OBS view extra of
dot
Okay so
so this here
is unsigned Char
observations this is actually going to
be uh map
observations or
observations map and then unsign Char
observations
extra
map and then
CNP Ray wordss and we'll leave this
hanging no let's fix it there we go
so so this is observations map extra
self.
observations I think this is the only
place we use it
right
map okay and then we do self.
observations
extra
hid
zero
playerx and this is a
uint this is a uent
here which is fine because the player uh
position can only go
from
Char I think I can do this maybe no
this
reward we'll do player.
reward do we do player.
reward or we do
rewards of
PID sub. rewards of PID
right I think this is a decent
architecture we have ability to add
stuff here we have a 2d map basic basic
basic starter
architecture
right super
uh okay so we have a few little bugs it
looks
like cannot reshape array of size
30 into 1 10 and
11 let's see what the heck is happening
here
yeah oh I know what's happening that's
fine that's
dumb this is like three
right uh other way
bada bing bada
boom this
works let's get
uh well the network is actually probably
kind of like minutes away from being
valid with this frankly We'll add the
config for
current we'll just like go add a s
MOA we'll go add us like aoba
thingy which is it going to be like the
grid
one it probably going to be pretty darn
close to the grid one right
on there
[Music]
are eight different
things so the grid policy it's very very
very similar to grid policy we've got
eight different channels on a
knit and then it gets
P 32
plus yeah here's your flat right
here there's the continuous
[ __ ] here your features your
features
5 by two Yep this
identical so pretty much an identical
architecture um there's one thing right
here this seven has to be changed for an
eight big deal otherwise literally
identical architecture until we start
messing with
it uh we should probably actually try to
make this run just to
see oh we should we should also adjust
the
uh we should adjust the batch size and
[ __ ] to not be like
insane uh we'll do like a
thousand 100
maybe mess with the BPT
Horizon we'll do like a th000 and 10,000
maybe that's
reasonable
um yeah that's fine
and num M's num
workers prob be
good 157k is what we
expect it just works first
pry that's so
funny that's so
funny okay so uh this thing just like it
works uh the main thing is that we don't
have a way to reset the environment now
so we need to wait for the environment
to efficiently reset
itself uh and then as soon as we have
that basically we can like well we can
absolutely tune this to be high
performance so we can like tune this to
make sure we're getting a million steps
per second train through put and then we
get this very very tight feedback loop
where we like design reward function
train model in 3 minutes or whatever uh
plot one plot on WB see if anything
happens log images to WB uh so we're
going to have like it gets old fast when
you've been doing it for long enough but
if you haven't seen this type of work
before it's pretty cool because like you
get the model to do a lot of cool stuff
very cool quickly and you fix like
dozens and dozens of bugs very very
quickly
um so I've got an hour or so no I don't
have an hour I've got I've got 40
minutes uh before I'm going to go for
dinner so I'm going to go use the
restroom real quick and then when we
come back here I'm going to make this
environment have fast resets that's a
very important simulation design aspect
it's actually probably one of the most
common failure cases I see with RL
environments out there is people put
tons and tons of effort into making
their environments fast and then their
resets are like a thousand times slower
or something and they totally lose all
their performance and then because of
the way they do their multiprocessing
they lose even more performance than
they should off of that so we're going
to go through that I'm going to show you
how we cannot lose perf on reset and uh
we're going to go from there so I will
be right back and then we will do that
and that'll set us up very very nicely
for experimental side work tomorrow be
right back
let's close this out with
um really really fast resets on this
m
relatively relatively easy to accomplish
usually it's possible I've made some
design oversights that are going to make
this harder than I expect but I think it
shouldn't be that bad
what do we currently do in
reset we reset a bunch of players we set
some Lanes we call compute observations
nothing here is
hard nothing there is
hard um in fact it doesn't even really
need to be
there well I guess it
does what about in it
this okay
so the way points only need to be
calculated once we don't need to do this
again on
reset uh the
towers everything can be pre-computed
for the towers when they're spawned we
just need to make sure that they're to
respawn reset them we might need to add
like a couple attributes for like
default or base or
something that's no big
deal ancients exact same thing no big
deal neutral camps same exact okay no
big deal easy easy
the one thing
is do you move on the
grid you do move on the grid don't
you we have to reset the game
board which is kind of
gross
yeah so
technically when you spawn stuff in like
this
right this isn't going to be that bad
though though cuz the games are so long
that this is going to be
function yeah we made it so that you
move on the
grid I mean no matter what we do we'd
have to have we'd have to reset a
grid also PID map has to be
reset so these two things have to be
reset I
we just reset
um we just have to store the original
grid
right
Star Rig PID
map and then all we got to do no it's
not PID map right it was a r
grid uh where's
grid grid yeah
here rig grid so we need this because it
has the uh well it has the original data
I don't know rig grid grid.
copy copy the
original then on reset
spawn
Tower this sets like spawn X spawn y
right spawn
oops Yeah so it needs to set spawn X and
spawn Y no big deal
though they're just like a few variables
we basically have to make sure don't get
screwed up
is way points are fine by
default so it's the spawn
Tower oh wait we literally the way we
did neutral spawns here is perfect we
kind of already did this for ourselves
right do we do it for
creeps I guess we don't do it for creeps
yeah let's just make uh so we have this
array neutral spawns right
spawns
and we'll just
right power
spawns and what we'll just do is
here oh we actually we need it all the
way up here yeah so Tower spawns the
zeros here prefix suffix yada yada and
then we do self. Tower
spawns idx0 is y and is X we no
longer need to care about the team and
the tier idx team
tier we do need to make a
spawn Towers function
and let's just go grab all this code
that we're going to
need uh we're not going to actually use
all of
tier let's just
do oops Tower spawns we're going to make
this for
dim we're just going to do that this is
like YX team tier or
spawn
all so this is literally just like C
death int idx equals z int idx and then
like four idx in range num
Towers spawn Tower like this that's
literally it
once we've extracted the data
right
yeah idx team
tier yeah it's
team idx team tier why yeah this is
correct it's Jank but it's correct and
this will get us this will get us in the
uh the ball game uh whatever in the ball
game this will get us on the playing
field at least for
I don't know insert
dumb thing here we need this so that we
can reset [ __ ] fast that's all there is
to it uh we no longer need this spawn
Tower we do
need self.
Tower team zero tier five we're just
treating the ancient as a tier five and
know it's kind of
weird uh and then we just do
team one tier five
perfect okay
so now we're not actually spawning
anything here if you look at
it we're just like setting up a bunch of
data so when we do reset
here we can just
do self.
grid of everything is equal to the
original grid and then we can do self.
PID map of everything is equal
to1
right and then we can just go
through the
agents and we just respawn all these
players they get their health damage XP
everything gets
reset
um and I'm sure that we're missing some
like variables so we're going to have
like horrible issues with this
but that should be all we need
um I don't know if XP reward will be
enough yeah because they need to go
towards the minions in order to get that
XP
reward which they're not going to do on
their
own that's going to be hard so we'll
give them a reward for going to the
uh for going to the other side and we'll
give them a reward
for uh
XP so technically we should make this a
four component
both
so on kill
um this needs to
be
CD
P
int
z p equals
and then what we do
is
XP and then we get the player has a
reward so we do player.
reward how much xp do we give them for
this I mean how much reward do we give
per
XP on kill what's like the max
here we give them a lot
though we probably don't want to just
give him one for killing
th000 all
right
and we also need to remember to reset at
the start of
Step player. reward is zero it's a big
common
mistake very easy to catch but common
mistake um so we gave them a reward for
kill we actually have to add it to the
player struct
right the float
deal and we also have to give them a uh
distance reward right
zero we
do player. reward plus
equals or minus
equals we need to get like the fountain
position right it's
obnoxious reward based on
distance
interesting that scals better with the
other lanes doesn't it versus just going
down
bit but then it doesn't drive you
to the enemy base I think we do it B
distance to
enemy uh
ancient so if player. team is
zero ancient should be get Tower
23 is the enemy
Tower
player
minus
okay e def uh float dist
ancient dist to ancient is going to be
the absolute value
of this
distance
yeah else get
22 and we can just even simplify
this CA
float then this is going to be minus
equal
by the maximum is 255 in
L1 I think giving a crazy big reward is
going to
be we're going to do like this negative
point1
observations self. rewards of PID so
let's just make sure that we do
um self. rewards PID yeah there we go
so that ought to give us something like
reward now we need to get the summary
metrics I think
working because I kind of uh punted on a
lot of the summary
metrics
so yesh
this is fine we get rid of this I don't
need
this
uh we still don't need this
[ __ ] for now this is going to be random
until we like Implement proper action
stuff or it's going to be the scripted
thing until we Implement proper action
stuff uh we don't need this reward fill
zero we do it on
cide we don't need self. actions equal
actions
we don't have um the reset thing
right
seated
okay so this is now resetting correctly
I
and what the hell happened
here oh I just
have the what happened to my client oh
it just loaded
weird I actually don't know what the
hell happened
here oh I just commented a bunch of [ __ ]
that's
fine or did I leave I think I left
something half commented Maybe
okay this is
fine yeah fix
that uh rewards. suum this is fine
reward you get this radiant
level Min radiant level this this thing
is not going to help us
now um because it's like flat
I guess this tells us for the first
environment which is
suppose and uh this needs to this return
function is probably needed as well
right bu rewards truncations yeah this
is
fine uh
let's let's see if we can get this thing
to report a nonzero
1295 C def not allow oh yeah cuz
it's let's just Define it up top who
cares
hopefully my mic is filtering the
background noise
int
oh um
yeah that's
right there's going to be so much code
clean up on this project
team and tier cannot assign type float
to int
uh
well this is
definitely oh
that'll do
it there's some stuff that looks like it
needs to be
typed
but this does
build uh does it
32 none type has
no that's fine
so it's not spawning anything which is
probably
shape
1206 entities
C entities.
view numpy Rec
array
um that's weird
this not convert
shape to size 110
why is this 1 by
206 oh m is one duh that's
fine
um so this doesn't need to be reshaped
right that's
fine probably doesn't need to be
reshaped either
step let's figure out what's going on
here I think that it's just that you
need to do entities of zero or whatever
cuz the environments are stored
separately let's figure that out I think
what's happening is just like I have
this structured element where uh it's
expecting me to
go here
okay
zero
of 5 col
10 do
yeah there we
go that's not
bad no big deal so the bigger thing now
is that the uh the just stuff is not
spawning I'll show
you so nothing is spawning
here so let's figure out that
happens self. ticket set to
zero
and is it resetting every tick or
something
Victory let's just see if it's resetting
constantly before it can spawn
though oh I'm
right that's real funny
get Tower 22. health so I guess when we
spawn the
towers oh we forgot to spawn all the
towers
de spawn all
towers and now if we run
okay I suspect it's not going to reset
fully cleanly
but there's your EnV
dire
victory that actually looks like it
reset relatively cleanly
right maybe there were leftover creeps
or something I don't know but scheme of
things that was a relatively clean reset
cool let's add like games played or
something well we'll do that later let's
let's just get this thing to to
freaking uh to run so we'll rebuild this
let's see if we run
train I want to see if we get rewards
now mind you uh this is actually not
taking into account the neuronet actions
at the moment
I just want to see if we can run the
data through the
stats oh there you
go radiant level Max radiant level
this is running uh I think 20 copies of
DOTA
now it's very slow we haven't done any
form of optimization on
whatsoever on the environment obviously
we have
you can see the forward pass is taking
up 71% of the
compute
so um how's our memory usage on this
it's a good question if this is leaking
then we're going to have issues if
not stable
2.49 okay well we can do a little bit of
optimization on this this will be fun to
see we'll see how quickly we can get
this to be uh stupidly stupidly
optimized
right I'm actually going to commit all
this code up and start this on the big
it's actually really cool though that uh
it has not crashed the environment
through that whole time that's pretty
impressive stability out of this
thing
670,000 steps of D I think that's
um this thing just played like three
hours of
DOTA now it's going to play three hours
of DOTA per second let's get it to
that so here is our bigger box
right this has uh this is in the puffer
cluster which I like to show off for the
stream
so we are running this now on this
Hardware this box right
here the puff rayi mini
cluster just literally a bunch of
desktops in a
garage uh pip install machine n we just
set up p
we'll get ourselves a baseline since
this machine's way faster and then we'll
optimize from here it'll be
fun the time zones for the stream are
funny it always gets uh more people
looking at it at like 7 p.m. Pacific so
welcome
multiprocessing okay so our Baseline is
this trains at 14,000 steps per
second uh this is like the worst
optimized possible uh many researchers
would be very happy to have their Atari
thing running at this
speed now let's
see config ocean
we should probably just grab some arcs
from like snake
right or
grid
8192 this batch size is really
large let's do 8192 though or 4096 to
start is fine um I think you don't quite
do
4096 because and it's 4090 which is
funny because it's the number on the
GPU um then we have to do o the thing's
kind of made for powers of
two little
awkward not a big
deal 4090 times I don't know
16 time
16 65 440
440 okay and so uh what we're going to
do is we're going to
run this is
49 copies of
DOTA per
core hopefully we have memory for this I
think we
do but we're just going to set this numm
is going to be
M's let's hopefully not crash my
box
uh okay well that works I forgot to
increase the uh the the config uh so we
just did the amount of training we did
before in like a second
fast billion
steps a million there we
go okay so we're at 500,000 train
steps uh we should be able to get a
million
I'm a little curious as to why the m is
running that
slow
24% it should be way faster than
this based on our
profile I mean we could always just
increase the core count and stuff
it's possible we made it a little slower
and might have to do a little bit more
optimization based on the reset stuff we
did uh let's do this MOBA perf
thing num m
is
49 we'll run this
for 20 seconds
slower in which case you know we can do
more optimization on
it we have more cores than two for
now yeah so this is now only getting a
700,000 steps per
second which you would still think would
be enough
[Music]
maybe
not let's just uh let me try a few
little things real
quick uh just to make the math easier on
myself I'm going to do this it's going
to be 100 environments
so we're going to do number of
environments this is per
100 uh so let's
do we need 400
environments the triple
buffered no reason not to do this right
I guess there kind of
is
we do
24 24m something like
this ah this might be too
much we'll
see we can do 8,000 mini batch size
now oh actually we should do eight yeah
this is this gives us better scaling I
think and then uh we can do 160k
maybe six is this 16,000 no we want
160k or actually 8 *
16 is uh
64 so
128 th like yeah like
this let's try this oops not mob
perf do we have anything running on this
machine
no oh wait this grid continuous thing is
still training isn't
it yeah okay this thing is good now it's
no longer eating my
CPUs so we just run it like
this like multiprocessing
is the chat working by the way uh nobody
said anything in forever I'm assuming
it's not
broken okay that gives us 600,000 and
the m is down to 1% which means we're no
longer bottlenecking on the end
whatsoever this is very
good I see we have very high
MK test yep it's good thank you
welcome uh okay
so I think we just need to match some
train settings now because this should
be pretty much one to one the same with
everything else I guess maybe the
uh maybe the continuous actions or
something
weren't handled
correctly let's run it with discretise
on I might have to fix something
do I have a disc res setting yeah puffer
lib environments ocean
MOA oops
[Music]
MOA uh
MOA let's see whether I uh I broke this
or not python
demo just run it like this screw it
could not bro broadcast from shape
two and
continuous got the mobile model it looks
like this is good
where is it getting
actions of this shape
from be getting them from the model
right the actor gives
you linear to
six oh right because this is not yeah
yeah this not remotely correct uh we
need to compute this
then uh
it's number of actions should be the sum
of this Vector up
here so 3 + 3 this is
six plus 10
16 21 22
six it's not six colon 9 at six
colon 16 I
think yeah that's like 0 to 10
perfect and then uh come on auto
complete
torch we just need to comment this a
little bit at the
end cool so now this
network should be relatively uh
reasonable this stack is not doing me
any
favors stack expects tensors to be equal
size well that's not
good
um the thing is since I'm not using
these
anyways I can probably make my life way
easier for the just for the time being
we'll comment this we'll put this
back and we'll
do Moa
not broadcast from eight into three into
six I do it
wrong so I'm basically here I have this
annoying uh action space I just need to
massage a little
bit right I forgot to update the other
thing so this is six plus this is uh
MOA or uh
torch so this
is this is 12
here
really I thought I had this
right oh I'm just dumb I just literally
literally can't yeah 3 * 6 is 18 okay
cool looks like it
runs I do VEC
multi that should be faster not slower
I do remember there being some weird
bugs though in uh P
torch like some of the optimization
operations so if this is way slower it's
just a janky loss we can fix
here we're making the action space
discreet for
now CBA with
this making it a discreet of
18 that'll at least let us I want to
just perf optimize this tonight is all I
want to do
I don't want to be dealing with annoying
pie torch like
quirks okay look this is just going to
go to a
discreet rate
18 or whatever and then this line has to
get
commented right here
if this still doesn't work we've got
something
right okay
so I'm assuming there's just something
weird with like the
way like we coded this with the
continuous actions and then probably we
just forgot
something I'm going to put the
continuous ones
back I'm going to hope that we can just
optimize around it anyways
there really shouldn't be a perf
difference between the
two if they're both done
correctly okay I see I didn't even I
don't even know if we changed anything
and now we're
at okay so it slowed down a little
that's funny but like
600k with the end being
fast I'm seeing relatively High volumes
of MK
traffic uh some of that can be infos
I don't see any info whatsoever though
so I'm
assuming I I set the in I set the info
reporting inal to be very
batch got very high forward pass
percentage time
time that's like nearly 30% of the
performance just in probably Cuda
transfers or something
weird perf to grades a little over time
as
well onto optimization
looks like it's going well too yeah this
is just the start it's not actually
learning anything right now it it is
running the policy um but we're just
kind of ignoring the actions and running
a scripted thing behind the scenes we're
just trying to see if we run the policy
to get actions in the loop with the
environments this is currently
simulating um 2400 copies of DOTA at
10,000 times and it's training at 10,000
times real time uh the goal is to train
it 20,000 times real time so needs to
double
this GPU utilization is atrocious right
now to
35% take a look at some observation
spaces Maybe
uh well this is also the weird
continuous version which we haven't
tested as well I think
so what do you attribute low uh GPU
utilization to Demons you know
demons what you got to do the RL
exorcisms for got to make sure that you
uh you know you pay your tithe to your
reinforcement learning priest
it it's mostly Cuda transfers and other
[ __ ]
Gins Ah that's funny the old
gorlin oh funny let so
um did we allocate this buffer
stupid were we stupid with this
buffer observations no we got un and8
here so we have un 8
data and then when we Define the OB
space what do we Define it as
correct we probably need to just get it
working with the
discrete action
first since that's like the thing that's
more likely to be stable
we just have to like redo
oops these numbers are actually fine if
we just take
like the zero off
maybe um
just do 10 per core is a little
mile [ __ ] it's
7:25 I got got to I got to get going
soon I hate to leave when the stream is
like doing so well
though but I am pretty
tired I'll get this one last thing to
work thanks for uh for checking this out
though always nice to see you drop by on
this we got lots of cool stuff
working I don't know if you saw we perf
optimized uh single thread to uh
13 no 1.3 million steps per second
single
thread which is what I promised million
steps per second
right where the heck is this stupid
thing
this thing is just
stuck
right thing is just stuck being stupid
are you implying it's running
multi-threaded now
yeah and if so how are SPS
lower well they're not what you're
you're looking at training throughput
now so yeah if you're going to look at
training through put that's going to be
lower
um that's going to be GP pu bottleneck
or Cuda bottleneck or
whatever but and there's some
circumstances under which the the frames
it'll drop lower as well because we
can't just have one copy of the
environment we need to have way more
than one copy of the environment um so I
think like when I was running 400 copies
it was going down to like 700,000 steps
per second uh which is slightly too slow
for what I wanted to do so I started
doing some other fancy things on 24
processes with 24 100 environments
there's a whole thing that's going on U
but basically like you want to have the
minimum number of environments that you
need usually uh when you're using this
many of course and you want the thing to
run such that the environment is using
like z%
CPU well not 0% CPU it's you're waiting
on the environment 0% of the time so
you're basically you're never
bottlenecking on the CPU it always has
data prepared for when you want
it and that you can reason
do what in the hell is wrong with this
environment
though I mean puffer lib's vectorization
is Dro in so like once it it literally
took me five seconds to go from it being
single thread to multi- thread cuz
puffer just does it for you and it's
fast now the thing that we're dealing
with now is I don't know if it's a torch
issue or like a thing that I coded with
the N weird um
yeah but something's
Jank
so you get this
thing you return the
action
it getting stuck on the environment it
shouldn't be doing anything with these
actions it literally shouldn't care what
it's getting for
actions step
all
render I need
this infos
dumb and
discreet we got this thing running
discreet yep
three it runs a few steps and then just
gets
stuck doesn't make
sense why the hell would the difference
of actions make it get
stuck or is it even getting stuck is it
getting stuck on receive
yeah it's stuck on the V environment
which is very
thread
one does it hang instantly
then seg Vault
yay oh I
know I think I
know no wait I don't know thought I
knows I thought I knows
one
idea one idea and then I'm going to um
I'll answer a couple questions if
anybody has any cool stuff but then I'm
going to go get food because that's
probably a thing that you need to
right
here this is float
do this is false self. discretize this
has got to be
false I bet it's just doing something
weird with the underlying
end I just pass
false I leave the actions
on it was just like a weird a typing
issue with a thing I was passing to the
end breaking
it CNN not supported that's
weird okay let's actually set this thing
to use a reasonable batch size
usually you want like eight uh what it
like 8192 mini
batch DOTA doesn't divide by powers of
two we try
so it does like to dip a little bit
after a second of
training I don't quite know why but
that's up to
800 I'm sure we can get that stable it
looks actually pretty well of course as
I say that it uh it
Flags very very weird actually that it
dips in steps per second like
that because um the environment is not
taking up any time you can see
it
so I don't actually there's nothing here
that should be variable
speed do I have something else running
on this
machine like
that's pretty weird the way that that
just
happens could technically be infos could
be a number of
things we'll figure that out I'm
sure uh whatever that is there should be
no instability so if we see 800k we
should be able to get
800k uh and then with some addition
optimizations let me
see what do we do here batch side BPT
Horizon
16 update
config I don't see anything here that's
bad
there shouldn't be
two now nothing there looks obviously
bad except the BPT Horizon which isn't
going to help
us yeah
but 600k we saw 800 we'll be able to get
it it's the same exact architecture as
the grid
environment so there's there's actually
no reason that we wouldn't be able to
match it there's like some Jank under
the hood that we'll have to debug I'm
going to commit all this up so you guys
can play with it if you want uh reminder
it's not actually like learning stuff
yet it is running it's not learning
stuff yet
okay it's in any
config
um tomorrow I'm going to try to actually
get models training on this
properly so we're going to probably set
up like a proper or reasonable multi-
discreet
space to start with um we're going to
set
up the actions to actually control the
agents we're probably going to set up
some sort of scripting thing for
targeting because targeting is going to
be really janky to represent early
on um but they're going to be able to
control movement uh qwe all that
and we will see if we can actually get
the models to like do something
reasonable that'll be pretty cool to
do uh and yeah other than
that I think it's pretty much set
um technically we could probably even
mix in like some semi-supervised data
which would be
fun but yeah that's that's pretty much
what we have for today let me show off
for folks that missed
it we posted a few good
things yeah 13 1.3 million steps per
second single thread which is like over
a gigabyte a second of data simulation
data we started at 150k took about 6
hours it was a mix of uh lowl C
optimizations or scyon to C conversion
optimizations uh a few algorithmic
things and then one big one was a little
bit of caching that we
did we fixed a whole bunch of bugs along
the way with this thing we got it uh
integrated with the neural network
policy just in the last little bit we
got the N resetting relatively
cleanly and this is now all committed up
so the goal for the next couple days is
going to be to try to get some
reasonable policies uh I I've done this
type of a thing before
and the biggest problem is usually just
tons of of game bugs and figuring out
all the stuff that's broken with the
game and broken with the observations of
the game uh we also don't have a full we
don't really have good high quality
observation data yet either so I have
some methods of getting better
observation data that aren't going to be
too hard we'll probably play with that a
little bit as well um but I think that
at the time being like we should
probably be able to learn
uh to learn a policy that will play and
win the
game high quality observation data it's
just really hard to extract this
portions of local state data you want
from the game uh and put them
efficiently into data structure that
goes into a neural network so like the
ways I did a whole segment on this where
I was like looking at different data
structures um yeah
the the thing that you have to do is you
have to find a way to represent the data
in a like in a way that you have a fast
neuronet that can process it and not
everything is fast hello and uh welcome
this is the little uh the tail end of
the stream 7:40 I got to go grab dinner
um I will be back on this
tomorrow I've been streaming the dev on
this project pretty much every weekday I
just pushed all the code so needs a
little bit of cleaning up but it's in
this any config branch in puffer lib it
is all open source
go ahead and start the repo on your way
in it helps me up a whole bunch and uh
yeah I will I hate to end the stream on
uh when we have actually pretty nice
viewership but uh I got to get food so
thanks all I'll be back tomorrow